it took
five years for me to get my first 400
000 subscribers
in five years i got 400 000 subscribers
and that was when you started vlogging
2015. daily vlogging that's right and
daily vlogging like i went from 400
000 to 10 million in like 18 months okay
i gotta ask about this because i know
that you were really sort of uh
not reluctant but maybe you had some
trepidation about oh
like what this is gonna represent as an
like obligation as it like the amount of
work and
you know i'm going to lose my mind like
and then you said alright [ __ ] it i'm
going to do it
like i'm terrified from a creative
perspective like
i feel like when i got on youtube
i thought i was like you know what i'm
only going to put out the most quality
[ __ ] i want to be like the quentin
tarantino
of youtube i want to be the [ __ ]
quentin tarantino where
when i upload a youtube video at the the
[ __ ]
internet the internet rejoices but then
like it became just sort of crushing
to unders to realize wait how backwards
the the youtube
consumption mentality is that like
they're only going to reward
repetition and and and quantity over
quality and i just like thought
[ __ ] man i've never been able to bring
myself to
like i tried it a little bit but but
just like from a creative standpoint i
can't put something up every day
and i know that for you from a creative
standpoint from like
you're like the the cinematographer like
the [ __ ]
you know the scorsese of vlogs
i can only imagine how much you lost
your mind
yeah you know it's it it's a tricky
thing because i think that there's like
the technical aspects the algorithm what
youtube rewards what youtube wants
there's all of that
and i think people put a lot of emphasis
on that and i think that that's
incorrect
i think that that is absolutely a part
of it but i think it's like 10
of it i think the other 90 is human
behavior
and so like i wasn't successful
because technically i was consistent i
think that the success came from the
much more human relationship that like
being a part of someone's life every
single
day and and who was editing all of these
that was mia you did how long did it
take you
to edit a video so it's typically like
i got it down to about a half an hour a
minute but it started at an hour a
minute
so for an eight minute vlog it'd be
eight hours of editing and in the end it
was a little bit closer to like
half that every day every day seven i
think i did 800 episodes of that missing
one or something like that
you moved that you moved out of new york
you're so frazzled that i mean that was
into
two different bursts right there was the
personal vlogging and then there was the
vlogging as the company
yeah i mean sort of it was just
basically like i think there was like
three or four
different framings of the vlogs where
like i quit with like a big
enthusiastic [ __ ] you youtube i'm out of
here and then like
three hours later like crawling back in
being like you know what actually i'm
going to start the vlog
again i i just couldn't turn it off like
i was so
when you when you have that level of
cadence like you were so completely at
least i was so completely enveloped in
it where it was like
the tail was wagging the dog a hundred
percent
like i had no idea what my actual life
was or who i actually was i
only understood myself as this character
and like you would live every moment of
your life like i can like
if i put myself there now it's like okay
let me think what did i do today i woke
up
act one was like arguing with candace
and then i went for a run
and then like act act one ends in this
drive
going from my house in santa monica to
manhattan beach act two
it's like i meet meet you outside your
vans demo and like we say what's up we
chat about the van
and like act two would sort of end with
like us sitting down for this podcast
act three would be us surfing get all
the shots need some dialogue gotta get a
gopro out there with us
then like the episode would end with me
sort of going home and then boom i need
a little bit of me at the house with the
family to humanize the episode
so i gotta capture that before it's dark
because at night like it doesn't look
right
okay and then that's it and then like
even if i'm pretending to be there and
be present and have family
like family hour with my family all i'm
thinking about is that edit i'm writing
it in my head
okay i got more shots than i needed for
that first act i don't need to lean into
the running so much i did that yesterday
the audience is going to get bored
i'm going to give 20 seconds of running
tops and i'm going to include that one
line i feel them into my camera when i
stepped on like a [ __ ] needle like
that's the level of like madness that
your brain became
and it becomes entirely monolithic like
i couldn't think about anything else
when people would be like hey can we get
breakfast someday i'd be like
i don't think they're going to know what
to do if i point a camera at him i'd be
like i'm sorry i can't
i can't meet you like lunch i'm like
sorry coffee it's like i literally
will not meet you you're not in the
scene god damn it i'm serious like
if it was a person who like i couldn't
make an hour to work with for my video i
just didn't meet people
right and when people would be like look
let's get together and catch up i'd be
like
how [ __ ] dare you how dare you
when someone's like yo let's go grab a
drink i'm like are you [ __ ]
nuts like first of all like by the time
it's dark time those are edit hours
second of all drink might [ __ ] up my
brain enough
or i'll not be able to edit on time like
how dare you
and it became like that's what i became
like i became a monster
and yeah and turning that off was really
hard because
the crazier i got the more it was sort
of rewarded
the more success i found sure i mean
paul
and i we uh edit all my videos
and and i think that like we can
intimately relate to the
the psychotic like like writing and
producing in our heads and this and that
and like
we collaborate didn't collaborate on
that i don't know how
you do that all by yourself and every
single day
so yeah 800 videos
daily vlogs yeah the first burst was 500
every day yeah which is 18 months
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude